haha hello freak bitches what a week
young Jim Norton has had what a week
what a week Sirius satellite radio has
had what a week censorship has had what
a week Anthony cou Mia has had what a
week all the the people online
they loved a bitch and piss and moan and
complain and get very excited when
something fucked up goes downhill
well something fucked up went down when
if you're listening to this if it's
sometime in the future because these
recordings will be saved forever
this is today's date is July 17th 2014
approximately a week go Anthony qu Mia
was taking photographs Anthony of the
Opie and Anthony show which our pal Jim
Norton is also a part of was he was
downtown in New York taking some
photographs and from there on it's a
bunch of you know what he says and what
I'm sure the woman who beat the shit out
of him would have a different story but
he was taken two photographs one of one
of the photographs was of this one of
those things called when you uh those
things we look our scaffolding
scaffolding who's walking through the
scaffolding a woman was coming towards
him it looked like he was just taking a
bunch of cool photos of New York there's
a bunch of him that he put up on his
Instagram yeah anyway this woman got
upset that he was taking a photo of her
probably thought that he was Pervin got
mad at him violence ensued she hit him
and he went on Twitter and went on this
rant about violence about the black
community and their propensity for
violence about this woman calling her an
animal what she did and serious fired
him and which left a fucking huge hole
in my entertainment world the open
Anthony shows my all-time favorite radio
show I listen to it all the time and now
all of a sudden it is no more yeah it's
a you know it's a huge hole to like I
know one panicked like me because Opie
and Anthony both have kind of fuck you
money Jim Norton doesn't so selfishly
thinking I'm like well there goes
everything because the show is done well
you're always going to be great because
you're funny comic thinking always work
and you never have to worry about that
but um it is a crazy thing uh that you
know all the
sudden like that for things that he said
on the show a hundred times I think what
happen happen was he tweeted like he
told I talked to him multiple times
since then
he was walking and people don't believe
that he was actually taking legitimate
New York photos that was one of the
points of contention people like he was
being creepy but he really wasn't like
Anthony has had this giant Hubble like
camera in the studio every day for
probably six months now he's getting
into photography it's what he's been
doing so that was not unusual at all to
hear he was out and about taking photos
that's the legit and I guess this woman
got angry and I talked to him and he
said that she just says something like
you you know this white boys take my
picture you white motherfucker whoever
she said she clocked him and he kept
defending himself and as he's putting
his arms up she is going don't touch me
like you know that thing like that a
woman might do to prevent you from
hitting her like you could see how
frightening that would be because then
people think you're beating on this
woman right so he's putting his hand up
and you know I know aunt well enough to
know he's not going to just punch a
woman in the face so she's doing that I
think a few black guys came around and
they didn't do anything to aunt but they
were like you know don't touch her so
you know and who is always armed and
he's licensed to carry didn't hit her I
didn't pull out his pistol and went home
and I guess was really upset and went
out like you said a Twitter rampage and
I knew it was bad the next morning when
I saw it because my ex-girlfriend called
me and she's like what happened Anthony
kept beat up by a woman and their I
don't know so I looked and I saw the
tweets i'ma go actually text him about
one I think I've ever done that before
there was one that I text around the
cozec you're right man that he's okay
I'm fine the cocaine was scary
Wow um yeah the thing about Aunt is he's
developed this sort of style of
communicating on the show where he goes
on these long hilarious entertaining
profanity filled rants and there's one
thing about hearing it but there's
another thing of like seeing it in a
text form this is not the same it looks
things don't look good in print
certain things and I think what happened
was is in the middle of like when you
have you have a contextual conversation
it's like you have people there's
inflection there's another guy next to
you going well hey what do you mean by
that and you're clarifying it or it's
just it's a different energy when you're
tweeting and you're that mad like I
think he'd like any type of an assault
even if it's a woman hitting you and
it's not life threatening is still like
you know an hour later you're like what
the fuck just happened like I think it
just freaked him out and she hit him a
couple times five times or so and I he
she sent me a picture of his face and he
had like little you can see that he had
been struck him he wasn't making it up
and so he went on and when I looked at
the the flow of things like I know
Anthony and I know what he's saying
he was not calling all black people
animals he wasn't because he's never
said that he's talking about a behavior
of this woman and I think that what
happened was he was so mad and when
you're treating that aggressively and
you've just you're fucking dealing with
this in your head that sometimes things
come out jumbled and muddied and like if
you know aunt you know what he's saying
people who don't know him are reading
this cord what does he mean he's saying
that there's violence in black people
and they are animal-like people are
putting these pieces of a puzzle
together and they're making a picture
and it was like it just I know him well
enough to know that in a conversation if
someone said are you trying to say black
people are animals he goes no not at all
it's a baby Haverhill based that you
know I mean because he said that about
white people too so I mean it was just
one of those things where once it was in
print it's even in context we lie as a
country like you know like when cancel
Colbert came out the the activists knew
the context that he was making those
Asian jokes in and didn't give a fuck
she still wanted to sink him she's like
I don't know I get it he was trying to
you know show the difference between the
same thing between this and Native
Americans and how ridiculous is but I
don't care so we gotten to a point now
where we don't even pretend to not
understand the context anymore we admit
that we understand the context and we go
after people anyway so something like
this is bound to to sink you because it
can be taken both ways unless you
actually sit there and talk to the guy
and each tweet has to come out like a
film each suite has to be a beginning
middle and end with no explanation
needed around it in order to to be
survivable makes sense well you know
what the big big key to
you said that it could sink you well it
only sinks you if you work for a company
and in my opinion that's unnecessary
yeah in this day and age it's
unnecessary and I I think you guys and I
think Anthony for sure would be far
better off with a podcast anybody can
get a podcast to put on their phone now
everybody's phone has a little jack that
sticks in your car and you play your
phone through your car everybody has
that now I mean it's not an uncommon
thing it's more common to have that Jack
that it is to have satellite radio most
people have to get a satellite radio
thing installed in their car most people
already have that Jack right you know
it's just it's so goddamn easy and I get
I bet you could get all the same
sponsors I bet you could get all the
same sponsors and you would have no
middleman and you don't look at the
studio it's not doesn't take much to put
something together you know a little bit
of time a little bit of effort you know
you gotta know someone who's an engineer
know someone who knows how to put the
stuff together and set up the
microphones but other than that what's
the difference between this and
satellite radio I'll tell you what the
difference is nobody can fucking fire
you you can go on some cunt rampage that
fucking animal cunt and no one you know
people might say I'm not downloading
your podcast but at least you have the
opportunity to communicate to explain
yourself and if the people decide that
they don't like your character based on
one thing that you said or one rant that
you went on that is their decision but
it's not the decision of a company and
when things get you know companies are
squirrelly man they have fucking
shareholders and stocks and they have
responsibilities and all you need is a
few slacktivism you know fire Anthony
and Anthony Kim we're going after those
sponsors we're gonna let them know we're
boycotting but mostly just noise mostly
nonsense mostly just soft targets but
all you need is a few of those in a a
fucking a company will panic they do
what happens is you know it's a billion
dollar company so you get guys like you
know Scott and Jim who runs it who you
know they're just a fourth of July
weekend was coming and then all of a
sudden they're getting phone calls from
the New York Post and The Washington
Post and although all the press
obviously has a narrative and they did a
shit job but the Washington Post I
thought was the worst offender with the
way they
covered it because the woman wrote
things that was just really it was
revolting to read which right she was
talking about Anthony saying that these
guys came around and she was saying like
you know all well I guess if a bunch of
african-american or however she said a
bunch of gentlemen want to defend
someone from defaming an
african-american woman it's okay like
that's what was happening she wasn't
acknowledging that Anthony was being hit
she acted like these guys had read his
Twitter feed not like it was just like
she read the Twitter feed in the future
it was repulsive all this all woman who
looks like the fucking fake deaf
interpreter from Mandela's funeral was
beating on Anthony but there is a
fucking it's a meme that guy has a meme
he's rules but that the company these
guys just get all the sudden they're
just they're home and they're getting
phone calls in the office the day before
vacation so what are your comments and
they probably weren't even that familiar
with it until they're getting calls from
the paper and they're like what do we do
with this and then this is what the
press does and this is why you gotta
hate there because I think serious was
going to try to write it out that's my
opinion because they knew a holiday
weekend was coming and this is purely a
guess because no one was saying anything
and then all of a sudden the press
starts going we have not had a comment
from Sirius satellite radio so we're
assuming that they agree with mr. Comey
his opinions they do this sneaky shit to
push you into defending yourself so now
the company with shareholders like you
said has to go well how do we tell
people that we don't agree so it's not
like if the press is the made them do it
but the press understands how to corner
you into giving a statement a definitive
statement because they know that you're
not used to this they know that these
guys come in to work in management
positions are not used to getting phone
calls going how do you feel about this
statement in that statement you know it
was really it was a very frustrating
thing when I saw it the press did with
it that that to me is always my biggest
complaint is with always it will dress
there's no nuance to the way they report
on certain things like this because
there's there's nuance to this
especially if you look into it in
character if you in context rather if
you understand that guy and you you look
at him look there is a problem with
violence in the black community to
pretend there's not a problem violence
in the black community is to pretend
that there are insane amounts of murders
going on in
go to pretend that there's not issues
with the amount of black people that are
in jail the percentage of the population
now are those economic problems are
those problems related to upbringing are
those process education yes absolutely
there's a lot of fuckin disparity
there's a lot of problems with poverty
there's a lot of problems with the
structure of our culture itself and that
you could attribute a lot of those
problems to racism to racism in the way
that funds are allocated the way that
you know the attention that society puts
on impoverished communities absolutely
efficient Eliza yes but to pretend that
it's not a problem is ridiculous it's
fucking ridiculous so when he's taking a
picture of some chick and she starts to
punch in him I think he's allowed to
talk about the problem with violence
with that community with the community
that this person is from that's beating
him up did he do it the right way no
absolutely not did he do it in a way
that could be misconstrued or construed
or interpreted as racist absolutely did
yeah he did he fucked up he did it the
wrong way he probably shouldn't done it
on Twitter you probably should have made
a video you probably should have made a
video explaining showing what happened
to him and explaining what goes on
explaining this 140 fucking characters
things he's a big part of the problem
dude absolute that's exactly what it was
because Anthony is so good at clarify
whenever you talk about race or a
million other thing whether it's
religion where it's so hard to make your
point without stepping in shit and then
having to go off on fifty digressions I
go no that's not what I meant no that's
not what I meant like you know that's
the worst part of discussing stuff is
that people jump in on the side what are
you saying that all people do we all
black - no I'm not so in order to be
able to get your point across you have
to walk an arrow you almost have to
close people's argument doors like a Get
Smart episode as you're walking this way
your point gets through and Anthony is a
genius at doing that a genius at it
because we've debated raised so many
times on the show and him and Patrice
would go back and forth and and Patrice
loved Anthony because he said Anthony's
an adorable races you know Patrice was
so funny with he never no never was
upset by Anthony's opinion
because Anthony would listen to him and
they would go back and forth half the
times Patrice was right and half the
time Anthony was right but on Twitter I
think like in that emotion when you're
saying XY and Z he I don't think he did
as good a job as he should have done of
closing those doors behind him almost
like sealing off things that people can
get to you on because he was so upset
because he had had a physical assault I
know it sounds like I'm talking in
circles and just defending my friend but
I've been with him for 10 years all in
this medium of totally uncensored and
I'm telling you I know him well enough
to know that he's like he's got weird
things where he'll talk about race and
people misinterpret him and I've talked
to him privately and the guy does not
hate black people and I know that that's
just all his friends defending him but
I'm telling you that he does not because
I know him well and then to hit people
going he hates black people think he's
miss not afraid of being misconstrued or
interpreted as racist he's not afraid of
it by saying what he really believes is
his opinion about certain aspects of a
group whatever race a gender whatever it
is he's not afraid of speaking his mind
about things because he's got that fuck
you money
that's a big part of it and he's got
150,000 guns those are two things and
you know a big part of it that drove me
fucking crazy
is people are not they're not taking
into account the reaction that someone
has when they get assaulted yes because
when you get hit by someone some fucking
stranger that you don't know hits you
especially when you've got a gun you've
got a fucking bullet launching gun
you've got a thing inside you that has
explosions you press a trigger
explosions propel bullets and they end
lives instantly and Anthony's an expert
with one and he has it on him at all
times and he's getting hit and he's like
what the fuck and so he gets on my
fucking animal cunt yeah bitch fuck you
this that you know it's getting hit is a
very disturbing thing it's I mean
there's one thing to get hit in a
spoiler getting hit in a sparring
session is infuriating with people you
know I've seen people go fucking crazy
because they get choked out in a jujitsu
session getting punched is way more
traumatic getting punched by a stranger
multiple times for taking a fucking
photograph I don't know what the
exchange was between the two of them I
don't know you know if if he was saying
something that it was infuriating I
don't know I wasn't there you know I'm
not going to pretend I was there but man
you got to take into account the
reaction that people have when you hit
them and it to me and again I hate to
keep going back to the press but they
didn't focus on the fact that he that
like he handled himself properly in that
because I know I would have I don't know
I would have pulled the gun on that
moment but I'm a panicky Pete and I
would have just been what other guys
were coming over I would have at least
brandished it and he acted physically
responsible like as a as a fucking guy
with a pistol on him because people get
shot all the time for dumb arguments and
dumb things he'd he handled himself
absolutely right and lost his cool once
he got home and people didn't take the
press didn't take that into account I
hopped on the fact that he didn't get a
police report and I wished he had now in
hindsight because they're all going mr.
Coombe you did I get a police report but
here's the deal had he gotten a police
report they would have just ignored it
they wouldn't have said well at least he
got a police report they would have
glanced over the fact and said yeah well
I only can get a police report so they
were just using that as a reason to kind
of ignore the fact that he got hit
they're like we didn't see a police
report all the press harped on the fact
that he didn't get a police report but
an sit response was look man you know I
know enough cops to know that me getting
hit by some lady in Times Square it's
not a fucking priority for NYPD who's
worried about terrorists yeah especially
if he's fine I think there's a real
issue also with with the press with a
lot of people in the press I'll clarify
that what they're trying to do is
they're trying to close those Get Smart
doors as they write a piece as well and
as they're writing a piece they are also
trying to placate all the people that
are going to be up in arms about their
opinions if they could possibly be
supporting a racist if they could
possibly be taking his side agreeing
with him seeing his point of view they
could be misinterpreted or they could be
interpreted as being racist as well so
they have to worry about that as well
especially if you're with a liberal rag
you know if you have a very liberal
newspaper that you work for and they
have a clear agenda which a lot of them
do the Washington Times does write
Alijah absolution post Rose there's a
lot of them that have
a liberal slant and if you are reporting
for them you know and it's something
like this that's very controversial and
something where there's there's a bunch
of things that automatically have like a
knee-jerk reaction to them and this is
one of them knee-jerk reaction to what's
conceived as racism perceived as racist
yes and another thing they do that's
even that's even more enraging is they
would people who write for the press now
have to do is that it's not just
reporting what happened it's how do i
editorialize under the guise of being
impartial right and they do that a lot
too and that I don't like either it's
like that to me is the worst crime they
commit actually it's the editorializing
as they're going along like it's
legitimate like like NBC and I'm not a
Zimmerman fan either aunt was a big
supporter Zimmerman I thought Zimmerman
should went to jail for something I
didn't know what legally I have no
ground to stand on but I kind of thought
he was a con but uh but but not a guy
who was out to commit a murder either I
thought there was a line in between but
whatever like NBC edited that tape like
ah can't do there's no reason to do that
unless you're pushing something but
they're doing it under the guise of
being impartial and I'm sure they've
done it plenty of times to vilify blacks
I'm not saying they haven't you lost
that lawsuit you know I know II did yeah
I'm crazy it's absolutely nuts I don't
know why the news has such a different
level of what they can get away with
what they can do because they're seen as
doing a public service in my opinion
though I think they lost it because
everybody was hating that guy and they
just want didn't want him to win
something on top of this the fact that
he still has his freedom the kid lost
his life right
I think he's us I think he's a sucky
fucking security guard that's what I
think I think if you're going to look at
that guy and find fault in what he did
it's how did he handle the situation and
what a more confident competent person
to handle it the same way like here's a
perfect example my friend Big John
McCarthy who's a cop I guarantee you you
know the referee oh yeah yeah yeah
referee caught that guy was a cop a long
time but great guy but knows how to
handle shit if Big John McCarthy saw
that kid walking in the neighborhood he
probably said how you doing man
everything cool you know they had a
conversation with him everything would
have been fine like even if the kid like
got up in arms or got mouthy with him he
would have probably calmed them down you
know without having to get into
some physical okay not only that the kid
wouldn't been able to mount them and
bash his fucking head off the ground
because he's physically incompetent if
you're gonna fucking could patrol a
neighborhood you can't do it just with a
gun it can't be you can't have the only
the last resort is your only resort you
can't physically defend himself he's out
of shape he's soft and doughy and he's
not physically able to hold that guy off
but yet he's put himself in this
position where he's like a security he's
the force of the truth of the law you
can't do that you're not you're not
qualified for that job he's just not so
when that kids on top of them bouncing
his fucking head off the curb look I
don't see any way out for him other than
using a weapon i when that kids beating
the shit out of him but he should have
never got into that position you should
never it should have never escalated to
that you tell me the only way two people
can communicate like that is it comes
into violence no it's how do you deal
with it how do you communicate how did
you address this person what did you say
when he talked back to you what did you
say what was what were the exchange of
words right you know and those those
things there's a big difference between
there's a video that we played the other
day um was some the G even lift bro you
ever see that guy the Russian guy is he
Russian there's even a worse one this
yes I don't know the back of Stanny kids
though in New York where the the Bronx
the police chief in Bronx New York was
like stop doing it you're going to get
killed like these two kids just go on
YouTube and they go up to people and in
horrible neighborhoods and are like hey
man you got a problem while he's holding
a calculator and he's just trying to be
funny but these guys are just bashing
your heads in and stuff and so the Bronx
chief police or something I said look
stop it but yet these videos my more
popular my point is if you watch those
videos the guy he comes up to people
that like look like the workout and goes
dude lift bro look how small you are and
some people handle it great
some people go you know like man don't
pull it up we don't need to see it
some people go yeah I mean I don't even
lift you know I guess I'm small and then
they laugh and they walk away and some
people like threaten them like it
depends entirely on how two people
interact with each other and I think
that's what we don't know about the
Anthony situation that's what we don't
know about the Zimmerman
it's not just about what went down it's
about how did it all play out how could
it have been avoided there's little
subtleties in language like when Jonah
Hill was apologizing recently and he and
he's obviously not a homophobe we just
got mad and said suck my dick faggot it
was a stupid thing in a moment and he's
other Tonight Show and I get he's just
apologizing I think he never had to deal
with something like this and he said
something he goes bandy intent doesn't
matter it's the words the words and it
was like again I know you're on the spot
in that moment I'm not gonna crucify the
guy but I wish I was there so I could
just appear on the seat next to him like
in that Woody Allen scene when the guy
walks out to correct the guy on line and
go know that the intent is everything
because if the words matter the next
time somebody said the fucking Giants
killed the Jets
well we better call the police oh that's
right it's the intent we understand
every every every single interaction or
phrase has an intent behind it which
which doesn't always come through in the
written words it's an inflection and
that's something that you and I had a
conversation about with the Tracy Morgan
situation with people pretending that
what he was saying when he was on stage
you know that he was gonna stab a son if
his son was gay like his whole act is
filled with him saying ridiculous shit
yeah this is not a statement son an
affidavit he's making court you're
taking it out of context because it's a
soft target if you do that yes I'm gonna
stab my son because he's gay as a
statement of fact or at the at the end
of a political rally is a pretty awful
thing to say but if you've opened up
with I'm gonna get you pregnant and I'm
gonna mold shit and make a hat out of it
it's kind of hard to take any one
statement and go well that's the serious
one but that's again that's that
purposely ignoring context or even when
you can't ignore it saying yeah we
understand the context we don't fucking
care it's just soft targets people find
soft targets and those targets look if
they're all ganging up on Anthony too
that's the other thing
I'm not saying boohoo Anthony right
let's pay attention what's really going
on if you're writing an article out of
the blue for no reason about Jim Norton
you're the only guy I think Jim Norton
is a despicable person and you write
this article you have the option to
respond to that and you can go well who
are you mister reporter dickwad let's
take a look at you and then other people
can take a look at him too but when
everybody's piling on it's a
free-for-all
it's a free ride and then
you're they're flailing wildly well
louis c.k actually raised a really good
point about that when something was
happened he goes you know you have to
remember to everybody's not googling you
like everyone is not googling Joe Rogan
or Jim Norton or Anthony Kumi alike so
you're seeing every result about
yourself and it appears overwhelming but
the reality is like people may be
reading Newsday or the post or the Glock
or vice or you know whatever they're
reading but they're not reading every
single article on Anthony kuma or on Jim
Norton so that's where the overwhelming
thing is sometimes misleading because
people are all reading little snippets
of it mm-hmm but when you know what the
companies getting calls from again five
or six different outlets to them it
feels overwhelming and like what the
fuck do we do with this because this
wasn't on the air so I think that's when
again they haven't discussed this with
me I'm purely speculating because to
them if it was on the air I'm guessing
they would have said well that's what he
does on the air but they're not looking
at it like well he was reacting to being
hit I think they just were like okay we
got a fire like I think that's why they
they kind of just reacted very quickly I
think they fucked themselves I really do
they fucked themselves because they were
supposed to be the place where it was
free speech this is the wild place but
we're the virus you would lose the virus
channel member now it's Sirius XM talk
that's it Sirius XM talk we have to
rename it but we don't know what they if
they have to did I ask you for input I
don't my name on the show like I want to
be on the show but I don't I don't want
to be Opie and Jimmy I don't people to
feel like I'm jumping in Anthony's right
seat because I'm not right um if they
call the Opie show I'm much more happy
with that because that's what it was
before he met Anthony call me I would
call we miss Anthony uh yeah that would
be kind of uh or Tony will call Tony so
they don't know who we're talking about
okay bring where's Tony no be sneaky
yeah but it is a horrible and it's like
people get mad at me and Opie and it's
like we don't and I tried to say like we
didn't mad at you for what because they
people think that we're like a bunch of
teenagers hanging out and like you guys
should walk and support and say first of
all you dumb motherfuckers that say that
Anthony I've talked to he wouldn't walk
and he told me dude you got to make your
money like and it's all a and B I'm
under contract I can't just walk I have
three more months on the contract
and I'll be tried to clear this up on
the air like if we just walk out if they
don't fire us and we just walk and say a
bunch more subs leave because they
realize like wow the show really is gone
then all of a sudden serious wants to
take action on us for breach it's a
whole fucking legal people just don't
get that part of it and they think that
we're fucking Anthony you know who
doesn't think we're fucking Anthony
Anthony he knows we're not fucked only
an idiot thinks you're fucking Anthony
but there's always going to be idiots
with opinions on ya and I'm fine with
that I'm when people say like dude I
love you and Opie but I gotta cancel
because I'm staying with Anthony I don't
get mad at those people or people like
I'm gonna keep serious I'm also gonna
listen to Aunt
I don't bog I'm fine with that too
because I get the emotion like whatever
they got to do to support aunt is cool
with me I want them to stay because my
in my ideal world they listen to me and
Opie and then they fucking listen to
Anthony there's no competition I'm not
gonna we're not like here you don't
mention Anthony you know when his
fucking show comes out I'm gonna I'm
gonna tweet it because I want him to
succeed because he's one of my closest
friend it's gonna succeed it's going to
if you you know just
he's an entertaining guy he's an
interesting guy and the platform of the
Internet is so free and easy and he's
already got a full professional set up
at his house yeah people don't know if
you've never seen one of the main
reasons I started this podcast is
because of live from the compound
because he set a fucking green screen in
his house a professional studio and he
was playing images behind him of like
the city of like he had a green screen I
mean a beautiful green screen poke like
professional broadcast quality cameras
like the whole deal I was like that's
amazing and that's slowly but surely led
to what you're seeing right here like
him doing that while he was already on
Sirius and Sirius tried to stop him from
doing that they got it they gave him a
hard time about that yeah I mean that
was it I think that was a contractual
issue to it they're like look this is
the medium you're on but eventually they
kind of like let him do it no my god
what do you think is going to go down
with September when your contract is up
October 4th I don't know I mean like I
love the gig I love performing but do
you love the gig the same with Anthony
not be no of course not no I mean I mean
the idea of performing either alone or
with other people right
I want this thing to work because I want
my own thing like I've done so many this
thing device thing yes Jim Norton show I
want to have my own thing too because
you feel like a more complete performer
when you're not always with Opie and
Anthony or Colin Quinn or louis c.k or
amy schumer's put me on our show like I
don't always want to be on somebody
else's thing right um so I love the idea
of performing on the radio I love doing
it with Opie I love doing with Opie and
Anthony more because I would say the
same thing if Opie left like I honestly
do love being a part of that radio show
mm-hmm being without Anthony is
difficult and hope you would say the
same thing it's it's just like it's hard
to realize how much space a person fills
in your life until they're not there
like I mean we all know Anthony's a
comic gene that's easy to say but take
the little moments like when there's
that chair I mean I'm called I I said
closer to I'm - Anthony that I do to you
right every day five days a week for 10
years and now he's just gone and it's
really hard to get used to that empty
seat
whether he's saying something funny or
whether he's just doing a stupid erock
joke or a little aside or just pie it's
like this whole fucking vacuum of this
this great powerful brain that used to
be you know a foot away from me yeah or
just talking about things he's a
fascinating guy he's got a lot of
information in his head he could talk
about anything for any length of time
anything he could be and we've said that
like pitcher and I've said this before
Patrice said that Anthony can access
funny
faster than anybody he'd ever known like
he just had the ability to access being
funny
immediately on any subject like if
you're talking like you know he was a
tin knocker he would put in
air-conditioning vents and he can walk
you through that in a fascinating way
and be funny about it and be captivating
with it me and I I just died telling a
story I lose people in me and it's a
joke I've done but I meant the sincerity
of it that if I was on 911 on the if I
made it out of the first tower I would
lose people halfway through the story
like I just have no ability to go from
the beginning to the middle to the end
and keep people locked in did you guys
have a meeting with
Arius after this now over I know Opie
hopefully talk to Scott I talked to
Scott on the phone and he goes look
we're gonna try to move forward with you
and Opie and see how it happens he goes
work through it organically on the air
they didn't tell us how to to do it they
didn't say don't man badmouth the
company don't he said work through it
organically on the air and what we'll
see what happens so I mean see what
happens and they completely closed the
idea of Anthony ever coming back I don't
think so um and they've given me no
indication so I'm careful how I say that
I don't want the fans getting like I'm
putting false hope out there but I'm
just being truthful is they it doesn't
feel final to me and maybe that's my own
denial or my own lack of willingness to
admit that this thing could be over like
it was really sad man last I saw
anything I went to his fucking fourth of
July party I was very depressed driving
home like I know I'm gonna be okay
financially and I know like hey this
other show could take off hey you got
standup hey you got but just the idea
that this thing you love to do like art
this chapter is closed like it just
fucking depresses me depresses me to
listen to it I couldn't imagine if it
was me every day day in day out being a
part of it you know I'm every time I did
it I'd loved it
I mean I had a great time doing your
show my favorite radio show of all time
without a doubt it's a real conversation
you have real moments and the laughs
somebody played for me recently or they
sent me a link to Jim Norton's laugh
compilation there's just times where
people have made me laugh on the show
and I listen to part 1 & 2 because the
point is not me laughing it's the things
and most of those laughs have come from
Anthony more than any guest or anybody
and some of the things that if he did a
thing recently or years ago that I heard
two days ago we were talking about
people who've shot themselves in the
head and survived and Anthony did the
voice of the guy who survived and he
just wanted to it was an immediate he
became the guy who shot himself in the
fucking head and survivors talk about
how he just has a more positive outlook
and I'm howling listening to it in the
clip and I'm listening to it uh like you
know yeah two days ago and I'm laughing
all over again like I forgot that bit
ever existed but god this cocksucker
made me fucking laugh and I'm not
talking about like he's dead but I mean
that's how
valuable of thing he is like I can I
can't listen to radio best I think they
made a big mistake I think they made a
big mistake for a couple reasons one I
think they made a big mistake because I
think it's it's going to open the door
more to the internet because people are
going to look at that is the only the
last remaining true free speech option
yeah because it that's what it is
look you can you could say you don't
like this podcast you can decide that
I'm offensive you can do with it
but you can't stop it I mean you might
even though the host might say we don't
want to host you anymore I'll find
another host
you know the sponsors might say we don't
want to be your sponsor anymore well
guess what I'll do it with no sponsor we
did it with no sponsors for years this
is the only real option
well you're your own producer your own
director your own your the whole thing
you're the performer you're the whole
thing that's where it's at because just
like a stand-up is entirely responsible
for your act you put on stage if you had
some producer hovering over your fucking
shoulder every time you wrote a bit
every time you were thinking about
putting together a setlist every time
you're going up and doing a show it
would review it afterwards that would be
gross they would take all the fun out of
being a comic yeah it would be awful I
think that's why I'm bad collaborator
because you're so used to having
absolute and ultimate control of things
so you're a perfect example think about
you and you as a successful performer
and personality who the fuck would have
ever thought you could have made a
mainstream career out of talking about
your love of trannies talking about shit
and piss and and shit in each other's
mouths and peeing on people monster rain
just look at the honest things that
you've tackled because you're honest
because you're funny
if you had to vet that through somebody
else if you had to have that filter
through some sort of a mainstream
producer it would have never happened
you'd never work you're absolutely right
I mean that's why you're right the
Internet is the last place where at
least I mean for now who the fuck knows
what happens with that but all that
stuff you did you did on Sirius Sirius
had a different approach when they first
came out they've slowly but surely
clamped down from that Condoleezza Rice
incident that's where I was like oh you
could get intro
for something that someone says on a
radio show that isn't even like a guest
yeah like I mean isn't even one of one
of the hosts right here's your show
could get cancelled a homeless guy yeah
and they were going to fire us that Eric
Logan Seder that was accent wasn't sure
it was it and this is how what happened
the fucking the NAB the National
Association of Broadcasters somebody on
that side I think was what was pushing
it because the story went on Drudge and
Breitbart will this hurt the merger and
again the guys who ran the this wasn't
about to merge will this injure the
merger and man it was a billion dollars
at stake and it wasn't going to hurt the
merger but they fucking panicked these
are all different people that are in
charge now but they're like well ah and
they don't know how to deal with stuff
so they get the phone call the guy Nate
I think was running XM at the time or
two Panero what do you think of this
thing they said a homeless guy said he
wants to rape Condoleezza Rice and felt
like like he's worried about a
billion-dollar merger and I'm not I'm
not defending them suspending us but I
try to put myself in there like and this
is again I mentioned Louie cuz he's a
good he's a good non-emotional reactor
two things and he'll look at things ago
well they're just trying to do this and
like Louis will give you a very logical
reason as to why something's happening
and it's like yeah I wish I would have
seen that I get too angry and emotional
and you're fucked I'm there say and then
I'll go like okay that's a billion
dollar company they're not used to this
and they hear this guy wants the fucking
first lady raped Bush or George Bush and
they're laughing about it merger might
be threatened to provoke them get rid of
up my Hispanics isn't it fascinating
though that you're talking about a
billion dollar company okay Sirius XM
billion-dollar company okay what exactly
are they selling well what they're
selling is content who delivers that
content guys like Opie and Anthony guys
like Jim Norton they're selling your
ability to be entertaining other than
that it's just music how do you have a
billion dollar company that's just
selling music well I don't that's what
my argue would be to it looked a talk
thing is the last like the last thing
you guys have and this is for any for
terrestrial radio to the last thing you
have is original talk content
and their point back would be that's a
great thing that we have but we also
have whether it's a celebrity people
doing shit or we have sports that you
can't get across that T we have the NBA
we have a majorly amazing we let you say
that's what they would say yeah but
nobody's paying for that let's be honest
they're paying for Stern they're paying
for Opie and Anthony
I hope so men especially since Spotify
and like those like Pandora they used to
be I like Sirius radio because I had
like the 30s the 40s the 50s whatever
and all the different radio stations
nowadays you just put Spotify put
anything you wanted as a you know yeah I
mean I I get almost all my shit from
iTunes I don't ever listen to music in
my car anymore unless it's coming off of
my phone I just yeah it's just I don't
need to you don't need to anymore you
don't need them anymore yeah and what
the last thing that the exciting is
things like Stern and things like Opie
and Anthony where you can have a guy who
is just freewheeling saying whatever he
wants doesn't have to worry about
language restrictions doesn't have to
worry about anything and the fact that
he get fired for saying the same things
that he's always said on his show to
saying them in a text message that
they're so ignorant that they can't
recognize that this is you're taking it
out of context you're taking it from a
guy who just recently been assaulted
you're taking it from a guy probably had
a couple of drinks and then when he said
it and he shouldn't done it he fucked up
he definitely shouldn't have gone on
that Twitter rampage you should have
said it on a video and you know what
Parker on the show up on a shelf on the
show it would have been perfect we have
been a great episode all that would have
been fun and and Keith Robinson pointed
out he's like the teasing we could have
given him all the teasing beautiful but
but I don't know if that's something
that we'll ever change like they may at
one point yeah we do kind of understand
that maybe he's you know he's a valuable
asset to the clique you know again I
don't I don't know why I don't get that
feeling because they haven't said to me
we'll bring him back would they really
haven't and I never want to give fans
I'm not trying to keep fans from
canceling it literally is just a feeling
a gut feeling he didn't drop and bombs
he didn't go on this and I've talked to
him enough to know what his intent was
and maybe I just this naive dumbing in
me but I keep thinking man he should
come back he can come back just give it
some time I just keep hoping for that I
think he can come back I think if they
gave it some time he definite
and come back in the context of what he
said it wasn't that bad you know I
wouldn't been happy if it was my company
I had shareholders and all that jazz but
I obviously I would never be that guy
anyway I would never be a fucking head
of a big company I'm just not built for
it but you got to recognize the
entertainment quality you know the
entertainment aspect of that guy the
entertainment possibilities of keeping
the show together it says without that
all you have a stern you know you mean
obviously you guys are still together
and it'll still be a great show but it's
not the same show it's not and you you
leave open the door for Anthony starting
his own thing some wildly successful
thing in the internet which also look if
someone comes along and they put
together some sort of an advertising
budget and they say hey listen we would
like to do the Opie we'd like to host
the Opie and Anthony podcasts on the
internet we'll take X percentage of the
the advertisers we've already got it
lined up we have a big launch we're
going to do it around Thanksgiving
someone's gonna fuck a turkey live on
the air you know whatever you know I'm
saying you start you start doing you
come up with some idea to do something
completely free and wild on the internet
a big advertising push by billboards
Times Square you know fuck serious we're
doing it on the Internet you know ona is
back and it's free downloaded online you
don't need to pay for a subscription
anymore anybody can get it on your phone
let me do it the way we do it we're
available on we're available online as
an mp3 we're available from iTunes we're
available on stitcher on YouTube on
Ustream on Vimeo if you just did
something like that it would be gigantic
yeah maybe the right man we have thought
about it and again we're up in October
4th we don't know and I and I'm we
honestly don't know what we do from here
like again Opie and I are doing the show
bringing guests in and just performing
and it's like we both feel the fucking
law through vice do it all through vice
there would be a wonderful promotion
vehicle to view guys to do Opie and
Anthony live through vice they'll set
you up with a studio do it all online do
the show as a video online and do the
show have it available as a podcast free
downloads they provide you with
advertisers wouldn't be hard to do
Shane could hook that up in five seconds
make one phone call and it would be the
wheels would be in motion I would I
would I would love to do that and that's
a guy's you know like she could get
really crazy and everyone's gonna be
fine